la question aux premières questions et
que tous les téléspectateurs se pose
pourquoi tf1 n'a rien proposé je le vois
tes hyper populaire et je sais pas et
puis je ne me pose pas la question
est-ce que vous est ce que tu en soit à
tf1 est ce que tu as envie de l'atf non
non je peux pas en vouloir j'ai passé
vingt ans à tf1 et j'ai très bien gagner
ma vie j'ai eu la cote de popularité
c'est gras en partie grâce à tf1 si je
suis là ce soir on may a tf1 on m'a
laissé faire ce que je voulais en est
encore la grande époque où il n'y avait
pas de politiquement correct où il n'y
avait pas de de ça ils n'avaient pas on
faisait ce qu'on voulait on était
vraiment en été on est on est honnête et
libre de faire ce qu'on voulait donc non
je peux pas je peux pas en vouloir
c'est vrai que j'aurais avoue avoir un
petit coup de téléphone de temps en
temps pour savoir ça se passe mais tous
les artistes que j'ai rencontrés qui ont
passé un petit moment de solitude monde
et le téléphone s'arrête du jour au
lendemain alors à l'oublier n'a jamais
été un dialogue direct on pouvait pas
faire autrement mais le big bill c'était
un barnum énorme trop beaucoup trop gros
pour regarder y avait quand même des
loupés oui nous étions au téléphone avec
2/10 semble-t-il
qu'est-ce que vous rappelle ce moteur
l'a pas grand chose
[Musique]
soutenir
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs vincent
que deviennent les gars faites assez
mais que deviennent les gafettes eux
rosa est retourné au brésil clarisse a
fait des enfants
jimmy est prof de sport line et a monté
une boîte une agence artistique avec des
danseuses des pom pom girls
oui mais surtout son tout parce qu'il ya
deux gars qui sont partis
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je veux garder de johnny l'image de
la se rencontre que j'ai eue avec lui je
m'intéresse à ce qui est écrit sur
johnny mais je trouve terriblement
malsain et indécent tout ce qui se passe
en ce moment
merci en tout cas tu l'avais rencontré
c'était pas une fois une seule fois dans
son ressort
ouais il était du devoir il m'avait dit
j'ai beaucoup comme tu chantes mes
chansons c'est la seule chose et voilà
j'ai passé trente secondes avec lui et
je veux garder c'est dur pour moi et
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui représente
tellement est faux il faut qu'il faut
que la france et que tous ses fans
gardent cette image qu'on a de lui qui
est le taulier un grand monsieur
certes à un prodige qui est à voilà
c'est un mec karamé et qui a donné sa
vie son public et voilà c'est tout le
reste on s'en fout ça va
moi j'ai une question sur qui tu a
contacté à ses 8 comment est-ce que tu
et a débarqué à 8 ha oui comme ça il ya
un an et m'a téléphoné genre est ce que
ça dit qu'on travaille ensemble
tu te dis oui et après pendant six mois
j'ai pas eu ce que je ne savais pas le
bon truc
et puis non battu battu ma part appelé
parce que pour dire j'ai pas le break
c'est vrai voilà et puis il rappelé ja
mais c'est là ça a été très vite a
rappelé il ya un mois près il m'a dit
écoute j'ai strike je t'envoie le synaps
j'ai lu le sujet et j'ai rappelé tout de
suite en disant si je peux travailler
dans telles et telles conditions je te
dis oui m'a dit tu fais ce que tu veux
j'ai dit oui j'ai envie de faire strike
parce que c'est un concept qui m'amuse
on en fait trois points on se mettra
autour d'une table après suivant les
audiences suivant la qualité du travail
suivant mon envie suivant l'ambiance on
y retournera ou pas je ne veux plus être
enfermé ans d'exclusivité ça a été une
des clauses yeux outre je ne veux plus
être enfermé sur une chaîne je vais
travailler avec france 2 pour fort
boyard parce que je vais intégrer
l'équipe de fort boyard
j'ai envie de faire des trucs sur rmc
découverte avec la warner pour parce que
je suis un fou des sports mécaniques et
des sports extrêmes
je ne veux plus être enfermé quelque
part donc je suis super heureux que si
rim donne la possibilité de remettre le
pied dans la télé strike c1
un quiz de culture générale qui se passe
sur douze questions
chaque question à 12 réponses on te pose
une question à la fin de la question il
ya deux invités et une personne lambda
qui joue juste avant qu'on propose des
réponses ont fait une partie de bowling
on lance deux boules on supprime autant
de mauvaises réponses que deux qui sont
tombés et ont choisi la réponse parmi
les réponses restant si on a la chance
de faire un strike on passe à la
question supérieur on peut gagner
jusqu'à 50000 euros
on accueille tous les jours enfin à
chaque émission on accueille une
personne lambda qu'à un rêve et qui va
essayer avec ses cinquante mille euros
de recette officielle arrive sur ces il
faut pas rater sur assange est une
question de posée oui dernière question
je te sens hyper up stressé mais content
d'arriver et ça me touche beaucoup
c'est pas chez moi je suis pas stressé
je suis ému
[Applaudissements]
braga c'est lui